so I know when you work on this movie
you like to be in the room with John
when you record so did you get to do the
same with gal here no I didn't get to do
the same with gal because she's making a
little movie called wonder woman in
England so that was unfortunate but she
is also so given the fact that you have
so much experience being in the room
with him when you're not in the room
with the character you're working
opposite is there anything else you have
to do to make sure you kind of spark
that same emotion because I love how the
relationship between you and shank kind
of mirrors in a way the relationship
between vanellope and Ralph yeah I mean
the one thing that helps in those
situations is they usually have one of
the writers so in this case it was Pam
play the other role and they're great
actors when they're writers so you know
the writing is great and we I do it with
Pam and she's amazing and there still is
room for like a little improv little
like stuff like that and if it were to
if there's something they that they
liked that affects the way the script is
then they would just do it that way with
her or bring me back or bring her back
you know it's we do scene sometimes
multiple times as they they grow or gets
they figure something else out or
whatever so there still is kind of room
to be loose and improvised I'm answering
way too long no go for it I really feel
like oftentimes when we're talking about
animated movies I mean nobody really
gives it the credit it deserves just in
terms of the mile-long list of people
that work on it the amount of time it
takes to make it so even bringing up Pam
having worked on both of these movies is
there any person that isn't maybe a
headlining name that you would call the
unsung hero of this movie that maybe
people aren't paying attention to
Pam ribbon she would be the one okay um
she wrote this she co-wrote the
screenplay she was there every time
she Redshank with me she read a lot of
the other parts she actually played Snow
White
she's a great mind and obviously rich
more and Phil Johnston are amazing but
yeah Pam I would I would bring up the
wall so with them she's she's amazing I
love having the opportunity to put a
name in and accomplish accomplishment
like that out there thank you for that
that's great another thing that I really
love about this movie because I'm
internet addicted and I'm okay with it I
like to celebrate it and oftentimes
everyone's like oh we need to disconnect
and then I see a movie like this that I
feel like is filled with a lot of warmth
and positivity so to spread that a
little more what is one thing you use
the internet for it that brightens your
day unlikely animal friendships I would
have to say just ours if when when the
news that I'm constantly refreshing gets
you down and you just feel like there's
no hope any of those stories any of
those like little hopeful videos the the
dancing neurosurgeon the you know but
but unlikely animal friendships really
do it for me there's a site called the
dodo and also nature is amazing that I
fall on Twitter and those make me really
happy
[Music]
you
[Music]